i'm just super happy to talk to you
uh so i'll start with that um before i
get into respect which i
really enjoyed um i am curious looking
back on joker
when you were making it did you have any
idea that it was going to be this huge
movie
no i mean i don't i was not given the i
was given the impression that it was a
risk
you know in talking to todd phillips
that like they he
found this space to make this movie in a
unique way
and i i i got the sentence from him that
he wasn't really sure or how it would
land
because it was outside of you know the
standard comic book
uh kind of format uh so no i i we didn't
know but i mean
i knew it was a big movie but i didn't
know it'd be a huge movie
i i completely get it jumping into why i
actually get to talk to you today
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
um and things that like are not in the
press notes what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of respect
that well i don't know what's in the
press notes but i i think one of the
the the sort of um attention to detail
especially in the muscle shoals
section in recreating that studio uh was
sort of insane to walk into that set
and to have it feel like exactly like
those pictures looked and also i don't
know if it's in
the press materials that all those guys
that were playing the musicians were
actual musicians so
there is a sort of sense that they know
how to hold their instruments they know
how to play their instruments there was
actual music going on
uh during the shoot uh outside of what
was recorded and tracked
that all those you know sometimes we
break into little jam sessions here and
there you know because i play as well
there was a lot of great guitars around
so so that was sort of
a a unique thing i heard that the
original cut on the movie was like
three and a half hours or a much longer
version
have you seen the finished version yeah
i saw the yeah i didn't see the three
hour version i wasn't part of that
process but i
i saw the two and a half hour version
that they're gonna release and it was
great
you know a hundred percent um what do i
and since there's no cameras around and
no one will ever see this uh what do i
need to do to listen to your
episode uh with david fincher
yeah ask ask david if i didn't send it
to you
right the answer would be it's not like
so weird it's
there's nothing controversial about it
it's just his nature i don't know why
fincher was like you know after two
hours like you know let's hold on to
that
i'm not i want to finish it i don't know
why there's nothing
in that episode that will make people go
like god that's why he didn't want it
it was it's just he's just an uh a
neurotic guy i
don't it's it's not a big there's no i'm
not hiding anything
other than just a basic conversation
listen i i've
i am not in your boat but um i have had
this happen to me where i've done these
exclusive interviews
and then someone has said to me let's
come back to it later i'm like the [ __ ]
are you talking about
like this is great yeah yeah who knows
if they get something in their mind and
you got to respect them i guess
there was no point in releasing it i
it's sort of funny to have this weird
bootleg thing
maybe someday i'll just secretly release
it
um for other people that give a [ __ ]
listen i i want to listen to it i'm a
huge fan um
so uh i am curious though you obviously
are so good at interviewing
how do you do you have like a typical
routine that um
where you how you prepare for a guest or
how much is on the fly and how much is
it you like the night before
you know kind of thinking about it and
working out what you want to get
talk about well i just try to like you
know get a sense of who they are through
whatever materials are available or
whatever
i think is interesting and i think what
really it's for me it's sort of like do
i
have a sense or do i know where i think
the conversation is
and will it happen so i get it in my
head
you know how i want to proceed you know
through some theme i have found in
in in in my mind relating to the
materials i've taken in of the person's
work and then i see if if it'll unfold
that way
so it's sort of an instinctual thing but
i do i do need to have something to hang
on to
and and at least to get things started
but that's
that's sort of how i do it i look
forward to listening to the david
fincher episode
at some point and congrats you were
great in this congrats on everything
have a fantastic day you too pal thank
you